oui parfaitement c'était une nomination
en tout cas qui était attendue fortement
notamment par l'Ukraine mais ce nom
Boris Pistorius il vient un peu comme
une surprise ici à Berlin en tout cas je
vais vous donner deux réactions
importantes celle du chancelier qui a
parlé d'un homme politique et qui est
très expérimenté sur les têtes toutes
les thématiques de sécurité et défense
il parle de la bonne personne à ce
moment à ce tournant de l'histoire en
faisant allusion ainsi à la guerre russe
contre l'Ukraine et puis cette réaction
de Robert abbec le vice chancelier vert
de l'Allemagne qui évoque les nerfs
d'acier du nouveau ministre de la
Défense donc Boris Pistorius qui en aura
bien besoin puisque de gros chantiers
l'attendent l'attendent évidemment en
première ligne la livraison d'arme
lourdes vers l'Ukraine elle sera sans
doute discutée ce vendredi lors de la
réunion des pays alliés de l'Ukraine sur
la base américaine Rammstein ici en
Allemagne on l'a évidemment cette
déclexion allemande est-ce que
l'Allemagne va ou non livrer ces fameux
chars de combat léopard et a refusé de
livrer jusqu'à présent et là on peut
changer l'Allemagne sont son point de
vue en déclarant livré c'est véhicules
blindés mardeur déjà mais on n'attend
plus en tout cas l'Ukraine attend plus
évidemment le deuxième gros chantier qui
est aussi les livraison d'armes vers
l'Allemagne c'est évidemment la
modernisation de la boule de terre et
vous en février dernier juste après le
début de cette
russe de l'Ukraine ola shot ça avait
déclaré un pour la Bundes verts de 100
milliards d'euros pourtant jusqu'à
présent les contrats qui ont été
commencés non non compris 10 milliards
donc il reste un énorme chantier cette
modernisation devrait permettre à
l'Allemagne d'enfin fournir ces armes
lourdes à l'Ukraine merci beaucoup
Emmanuel cha